it's dessert time I'm James Brazil
director of culinary research here at
the Institute of Culinary Education
today we're taking your candy aisle
favorites and making a gourmet dessert
let's do this first thing we're gonna do
is take some candy cookies and ice cream
and transform them into a beautiful tart
we're gonna start out here just with a
bit of vanilla ice cream have that out
to soften up a little bit maybe a little
runny that's all right don't worry about
it we're just gonna take that and mix
that up it's very soft though it should
be okay we're gonna throw a little bit
of candy and cookie into there I'm gonna
take some of our cookies here chop them
up throw them right in some of the
greece's pieces my personal favorite
chop them up a little bit and they're
gonna get mixed in here a little bit of
vanilla ice cream get all that good
stuff in there if I were sitting at home
no one else watching I'd be on the couch
with this bowl done but we're gonna do
this up more cookies here there's gonna
make a little base of our tart that'd be
super fun I kind of like you know they
have a little bit more texture you get
some of those creamy bits you get some
of the cookie bits and we're just gonna
take those and spread them in right to
the base of our little molds here so
we're set with that and then we're just
gonna spoon that ice cream mix right
over the top gonna settle in all of
those little nooks and crannies and then
just level the top and then here's where
you can have some fun we're gonna take
these candies and just start lining them
up across the top you can make any kind
of pattern or shape you want may have
gotten myself a little trouble with this
idea I was thinking monochromatic
doesn't take away to only to pick
through all this you can do this with
any type of candy you could use M&Ms you
know if you wanted to go skittles for a
little more color you could but these
ones you know with a nice crisp shell
like this tend to do the best okay I
made it we're gonna take these off to
the freezer let them set up and we'll
get back to it every great dessert needs
a sauce so what we did here is we took a
little bit of heavy cream some bourbon
and strawberry fruit roll-ups and just
simmer those down so it was a nice thick
creamy sauce to kind of get a
strawberries and cream thing with a
little kick
bourbon I'm from the South I love to
throw a little bit of bourbon in there
but look you don't have to have it at
all just your fruit roll-up and a little
bit of cream and you're gonna be a
beautiful sauce so we're gonna take a
bit of that sauce drop it right here on
the plate get all the extra off the
spoon and then give it a little
perfectly sloppy so that kind of sets
the frame for our plate we're gonna come
back to that ice cream tart out of the
freezer I'm just gonna run this around
lift it up set it down right there looks
fantastic I've got all those Oreo
cookies on the bottom that's actually
beautiful exactly as it is but we can do
better
we're gonna take some fresh strawberries
and just kind of arrange them around the
edge it's coming down one side we've got
our Twinkies tear it up into some little
chunks kind of tuck it in there with the
strawberries so we've got like a little
Strawberry Shortcake thing happening get
that in there looking good
bring it home with our mint like a
couple nice fresh leaves right in there
and there it is
gourmet dessert out of the candy aisle
you guys may think it's junk food but
you're gonna have a lot of fun with this
put your own spin on it plate it up
beautiful let's see what you got
[Music]